do you think men and women can just be
friends
yes yes
i've always said that in most cases a
man or woman can be friends if the man
isn't attracted to the woman no and then
your friend gets your heart accidentally
for instance
i would hope my influence will make her
choose the right friends to be with
based on how they can impact our
relationship but i don't think that's my
final choice do you not think if if a
man said to her like like if she said i
want to have sex with you all the male
friends will say yeah let's do it that's
yeah that was an experiment yeah but i
don't know where you're going with that
yeah there was an experiment on youtube
right this guy stopped
couples in the street and says okay
does he does a girlfriend have a male
friend yeah yeah i like her whatever
yeah so okay we'll do it we'll run an
experiment
get the girl
call your mate friend right now yeah
pretend you're in love i've heard of
that and say
i want to have sex with you
since you have since you have male
friends would you call one on the show
no and see if you didn't have sex
exactly no because do you think they'll
say yes it's primal in a man to just be
like oh yeah but that's that's what i'm
saying like they wouldn't be friends but
if you were three hundred fifty they
wouldn't
they wouldn't be friends with you if you
if you were 350 pounds they're friends
with you because you're attractive
like no guys are that excited to hear us
talk but there are men that like 350
pound women
there's a couple but that's usually
because they can't get the hot chicks
and you see that because okay jesse
williams who's jesse williams you don't
know who jesse grayson yeah okay
how many times why do we hear the term
trophy wife because it's like a wife
that's a trophy and she's good-looking
yeah but they're boring yeah
why do you just assume that because you
could just that's probably why the mail
like give me example of a choice if
someone like
um christian
christian
melania does she look like she's in love
with trump you can have he's got all
power in the world that's a trophy i
mean that's a trophy does she look like
she's smart too she knows three
languages oh that's cool yeah she's no
she's smart
i'm saying like you can't just assume
just because they're pretty they're
boring
that's like to me that's like a mating
strategy
cristiano ronaldos like who's the one
that they that he picked her up off of a
shoe store was that cristiano ronaldo i
don't know yeah
yeah i think there's a lot of trophy
wives that are very happy because i
almost think they're happier because
they understand their roles but do you
see that there are the media showing us
what do you think that's what the media
show that they're happy
um i i don't know celebrity
relationships are always a weird so so i
don't know but i'm saying like
i i think when you're in a relationship
where the man and the woman understand
their roles they tend to be happier it
is my i don't know
when it's a trophy wife like usually i
mean like a girl that stays home and
raises the kids
and then do you think the man's probably
all right that's my wife she's got her
role she's got her payroll she's i'm
doing this do you think that he's gone
out and had something more fun because
that's his wife i don't know well
probably no i mean men that make more
money like get the option to cheat more
so more of them do sure but i think
women cheat more than men do you think
his wife is cheating now
i i think it depends i think it depends
but i don't know what your point is like
all all couples have problems just
because she's hot doesn't mean that she
offers she's like she's boring i think
that's a mating strategy women use to
like like to
make them less competitive is it say
that the hot girl is boring or she
doesn't have any brains or whatever no
no i'm not saying she's not i'm not
saying she's silly i'm just all done
yeah i'm just saying that she just i
don't know what she looks like it's bad
yeah but obviously you know what
cristiano looks like but i don't know
his wife yeah i didn't have a clue yeah
is she is she really pretty is she um i
i don't think she is stupid pretty i
don't know i think i don't know i don't
know
i've just heard they have a very like
cute relationship i don't really know
see that's me back to what we're saying
if you if you let your girl have male
friends then um it's not you might trust
her but
you know they could they could
disrespect you whenever i hear you don't
have the same but the reason why i can't
just say no
is because there can be there might be a
manner in her life
that has been so invested in her life
from a young age that she he might have
a part to play in her maybe mental
sanity for example so for example my
last girlfriend
she lost both she lost both her parents
her boyfriend was like a rock
they broke up i can't tell you why they
broke up i don't know but
he was so instrumental in her keeping
her sanity i can't just now say you
can't speak to me you don't need to be
with us that's don't be with us that's
just smart wait wait i'm the neuro wait
i'm the youngest yeah
so because she was like there for her
before
you allowed her to be friends with her
ex and you continued to date her
yes but the reason why that's crazy i i
hate you i hear you he's a rock are you
a feather
so
i was only with her for a short period
of time what i'm saying is that there
was a part of her life i don't know
about
yeah i don't i didn't know what she went
through but he did so you want her to be
with a dude that knows more about her
life than you no it's not even that's
let them be together it's not even that
though it's not even that it's a
situation where until i was i didn't i
didn't get enough because i wasn't with
her for a long amount of time i didn't
find out about all the history so
because i didn't find out about audi
history i wasn't able to replace him
are you friends with some of your access
to me yes no i don't i don't i don't
chat do you have a lot of girls that are
friends i've only ever had one
girlfriend right no no friend girl star
friends
not really female so the only girl you
picked to date was the girl that was
friends with her ex
i i get why you allowed it but i'm just
saying it won't run with me like which
is which is perfectly fine but what i'm
not gonna do is just automatically say
okay cool because i know how men are
automatically
you can't talk to any man because i know
how they are because i don't think
i didn't know her past
and i did and i didn't give myself
enough time to find out about her past
what i'm saying and she went through a
lot of stuff in the past maybe it was a
short thing yeah i was only over there
for like nine months right so because i
wasn't even for a long amount of time i
didn't know all that history to then say
okay cool i can now take you why did you
two break up can i ask for the reason
i'm curious
so the reason why we broke up was
because so she said she liked me but i
never at that moment felt the same way
but she was the first person to ever say
oh i like you so it made me feel a kind
of way so i thought and i would i wasn't
really
i wasn't really taught a lot about this
growing up so i kind of had to learn
from myself right so i thought okay cool
she said she likes me i think she's
pretty maybe i can grow into this
these times i'm going to university so
i'm going to university i was working
and i'm an athlete as well so i really
had no free time you weren't ready and
what happens is the level of
commitment and
attention and the seeing i couldn't
offer it
you you went that into her that's what
you allowed i think the universe
conspired to save you man doubt that
that would trust me probably got saved
probably but but because was the first
person to ever say that i was like okay
i actually got excited because
me as a man i don't really get told in
kind of things so i got excited i
thought maybe i can go into it and the
more i'm in that relationship more i'm
realizing
i'm not really on you like that that's
what i'm saying so
i saw i i i broke it off because i said
i can't give you
what i feel you need did so it's better
you find it from someone else
let me be half-height and did she did
she talk to her ex like the whole time
you were together no no at the time not
all like but like like when you guys
broke up was she still in contact with
him chatting to us i don't know you
don't know like a month before like if
she was still talking to him
maybe maybe
i think we can assume based on the
importance he's had in her life then
they probably were talking so maybe yeah
have any of you had girls that were
taught him to the exes when you just met
them more
um
not i know like if if i'm going to take
it serious then those are the questions
i need to ask
and if it's a yes then
just a smashing pass i guess
what about you
no no what about you no no
okay um
so this is kind of going back to the
original topic we get a little bit off
and we went to carnival
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible